[Music]
[Applause]
he's Rex Chapman he's launched a new
podcast it's called owned where he takes
a deep dive into the world of pro sports
owners he's talking to a journalist and
athletes comedians actors and even the
owners themselves you got uh you're
going to be doing Marge shot Donald
Sterling Vince McMahon uh the late Jerry
Buss and Rex joins us from New York City
look at you you're an entrepreneur is
what you are yeah that's what they call
me I'm glad that uh when you think of
the Rough and Tumble 80s and 90s
basketball you think of Rex chat yeah
that was bad basketball back then
games were played in the 70s and the 80s
and the 90s aesthetically even though
you had the greatest player you had the
greatest players with burden and magic
and Michael and you know they they had
so much physicality to it that they
didn't have the free-flowing you know
sort of artistry that you have now
no question I mean it's it's so fun to
watch now guys are so good you know back
in the 80s and 90s we still had bigs
that played traditional bigs that you
know some of them weren't as skilled and
uh now you can't team switch everything
one through five big guys can guard like
guards big guys can shoot like guards so
it's just a fun game to watch right now
and everybody seems like everybody's way
better with their offhand than they used
to be all right how do you categorize
The Joker we we love to do player comps
we love to say reminds me of it's almost
like he's a he's a hybrid of uh quite a
few players
I think he's a seven foot Steve Nash
he's a seven foot point guard he's
playing at a okay he brings brings the
ball up the floor he can shoot the ball
you wish he shot it more because he
shoots a high percentage he's the most
dominant low-post player in the game we
have right now but physically if you
look at him you go man he's at a Miss
he's guys have a mismatch with him
athletically every single night and they
can't do anything with him the same way
they thought people thought about Steve
Steve would play against Baron Davis and
we'd go oh my God how's he going to do
that but he did it and you know he's
getting triple double doing it yup
Joker's no joke man he's he's the real
thing but also when you factor in and
I'm hung up on this when uh Perkins said
this on the mothership that he pads his
stats and I go tell me a guy who has 50
other players in the regular season who
shoots more field goal attempts than him
and tell me he's a guy who's patting his
stats
not I I I love park I think perk's
terrific he's fun to watch I don't
always agree with Perkins I definitely
didn't on this one uh the guy is just
dominant he might not be the prettiest
thing to look at you know if you think
about he's he's more like he's like Tim
Duncan you know he's kind of a plotter
he the wave runs up and down the floor
he's not the most fluid player in the
world you look at the end of the game
and he's got 20 and 20. I mean the guy's
just something else and the way he
passes the ball I just found out
recently some of that is a product of
him playing water polo growing up did
you know that yeah I just found that out
yesterday
that's amazing but if you see how he
holds the ball Rex
yeah it's waterfall and you've got you
got to be a great athlete to do that I
don't know how much water polo you've
watched we didn't have much of it on the
East Coast uh growing up then but uh
water polo players and you got to be a
great swimmer so he's all kinds of a
good athlete he's just not the
traditional athlete we look at but we're
looking at the European basketball
player and we've changed our opinion
because the best players in the NBA are
not from the United States they didn't
play college basketball would we think
differently of
you know jokic if he played it Duke for
one year or Giannis if he played one
year or Luca because it feels like we're
slow to embrace them as man they're good
it's like I agree I don't know I agree I
agree you know when I first came in the
league I think uh the first foreign
player was sarunis Barcelonas uh or one
of the first and you know the league was
not it didn't really welcome sirunas all
that well and slowly but surely we had a
couple other guys that would play in the
league and uh you know at first we we
looked at European basketball like it
was you know a step down it's not a step
down anymore if you go watch uh anybody
play overseas it's real basketball real
basketball is being played everywhere at
this point
the heat didn't make it to a game six or
game seven because of what
uh uh because they ran out of juice I I
think Jimmy was exhausted you know you
can only
lose guys so much and continue to to
plug them in uh guys are playing more
minutes you know that
I got to to have a guy like Tyler hero
goes up go out uh 20-point score and
then be able to still make it to the
finals damn near win it all it's just a
testament my first year down in Miami as
a player was Pat's first year Pat
Riley's first year as the coach down
there and Eric spolster his first year
as the I remember Eric coming in late at
night with the old remember the CDs they
would he would they would burn CDs that
would have all of our highlights or low
lights on it and about three o'clock
every morning I would hear Eric come by
the door and flip a CD under my under my
door so I was supposed to watch that
before practice
uh and hard to believe that's 25 years
ago
um but Eric just continues to do it the
system that they have down there they're
always going to be in games because
they're disciplined their defense
prevails and they get guys that are
committed to winning and playing the
right way it's just beautiful to watch
He's Rex Chapman NBA TV studio analyst
former NBA player and his new podcast is
owned
what fascinated you about doing a
podcast on owners
well uh if you remember I had a great
run with CNN plus that show was just
fantastic as you might remember no it
wasn't it was but
it ended they blew up CNN Plus in a
month so anyway I was in New York and
after that I got a call from uh the guys
at smartless
did you leave your car running at CNN is
is that how short your stay at CNN was
yeah
yeah I've moved up there and could it
drove up and could have driven pole yeah
uh right back to Kentucky no it was a it
was a terrific experience and then but
from that
um you know I had some time and guys at
smart list the podcast Jason Bateman
Sean Hayes Will Arnett those guys have
created a fantastic brand uh with their
podcast and they've spun off a couple
podcasts and this one I'm really excited
about is their first one about sports
it's about sports owners and
The more I've gotten into it the more
I've realized you know we haven't done
enough on Sports owners over the year in
the media
um this is It's fascinating
um I think you mentioned some of the
people we've got we've had Russell Crowe
who
he that episode came out yesterday first
episode with Russell Crowe and learning
that story I I found it just fascinating
Dan that you know we have these famous
people Russell Crowe Natalie Portman
Natalie Portman owns the angels in Los
Angeles now Russell Crowe owns his
childhood rugby team that he bought from
Rupert Murdoch in the like 2004 for
three million dollars it had run into
the ground he put some money into it
they win the title 10 years later and
the team's worth 85 million dollars
today and Russell Crowe's done some
amazing things in this life but you
should hear him gush about this football
rugby ownership it's just a lot of fun
yeah it's like whenever you talk to an
actor they want to they don't want to
talk acting they want to talk sports or
if you talk to a musician they don't
want to talk music they want to talk
sports I run into this all the time uh
let me uh hit you with a couple of
things here in the off season yeah uh if
you're Portland
do you trade Dame Lillard
I
I think you probably do I I you know
he's been as loyal I love being lowered
a huge fan of Kevin as a player but also
as a person I've gotten to know him over
the years and you talk about just the
humble guy that goes out there he comes
to play every single night I just feel
like that franchise he's given that
franchise the best that he can give him
I'm just not sure that they can get
there with him uh putting other pieces
around him at this point so I I do feel
like it's probably time to move Chris
Paul
best place for Chris Paul to land is
where
Phoenix
I think Phoenix I still think Phoenix
um you know he's he's going to have
options Chris Paul is one of the
greatest point guards we've ever had in
this league I can't believe he's still
playing at such a high level at age 37
um but it whether it's Phoenix or
somewhere else somebody's going to pick
up Chris and and get somebody that's
highly motivated to win right away but I
still think there's a chance Phoenix
keeps it okay so he comes back for less
money because I think he's scheduled to
make 30 million do they would he come
back under those circumstances I don't I
don't know the answer to that I I I
really don't yeah because I don't know
if he just says you know what it's a
slap in the face they're not going to
pay me 30 million uh Lebron I'm uh I'm
ready to come help the Lakers
well do you think LeBron wants it well
that's that's what I wanted how does
that work if you're a player and your
buddy wants to join you but you're not
sure if your buddy can help you get to
the next level uh you know I think maybe
we saw a little bit of that with
um Carmelo because Melo you know was
kind of out there and then LeBron and
mellow went there and he did his best uh
you know he was just running on fumes at
that point I don't think Chris is there
I think Chris still has gas in the tank
yeah I'm curious about that Kyrie it
feels like he he's going to resign with
Dallas that makes the most sense
it seems like that it seems like they
sort of have to right I mean they gave
up a bit to get him and uh to lose him
to lose him for nothing or to not turn
him into what you know to not get the
value from Kyrie Irving that you would
hope to get and I think you do have to
resign okay but how do you deal with a
teammate
and I don't know if you ever had a
teammate who was anywhere near what
Kyrie is and that is extremely talented
but you're not quite sure what you get
every single day personally with him
um I think it's I think it's that's
difficult you know you know how it is
Dan you've got your team right there
with you you being being on a team is is
way bigger than yourself and I think you
have to you know we've we've seen Kyrie
so good we've seen that he's able to
give of himself enough to win a title
he's done that once with LeBron
um he hasn't been able to do it without
LeBron and I think that that's a that's
something that he that he probably is
trying to address
um but yeah I I I think Dallas has to
resign uh Kyrie does he work with Luca
though
I I think that's a valid question for
anybody does X work with Luca we don't
know the answer to that yet does anyone
um we've shown he's he's a fantastic
player but they're both so ball dominant
I'm not sure how that really works yeah
I brought this question up to Reggie
Miller yesterday I said would you rather
have Luca
or jokic
and he said jokish jokic
yes but a year ago or two years ago you
might have answered it differently
maybe maybe I guess you know we're
starting to hey we fall in love with
guys who come right into the league we
everyone fell in love with the Zinger
remember that a couple uh porzingis yeah
uh in New York and then he was the next
you know he was off everybody's list so
yeah I I'm a I'm a I'm a Luca guy I
believe in him and again you've seen him
working out this summer if that dude
ever is able to get in shape and be in
shape at the beginning of the year look
out
look out
what do you remember from the slam dunk
contest
losing
that's it
that's it the first year I lost to
Dominique Wilkins which not everybody
can say there's there's a contest the
Dominique no shame in that
yeah and then the next year I felt like
I got robbed a little bit I uh was uh
in Charlotte and the Hornets really
wanted me to do it I didn't want to do
it again and uh they versus they kind of
twisted my arm and made me do it and
then uh D Brown pulled out his that dunk
and where he covered his eyes and pumped
up his sneakers and do you think D Brown
actually covered his eyes Rex
no of course not okay okay it's like
said ceballos with him see-through blind
wait wait said cibolos could see through
the blindfold
what are you talking about
uh well you were at least in you know
white men can jump I mean yeah I was
third in the dunk contest one time so
yeah I'll take it I guess behind Shawn
Kemp and D Brown
so those when you're getting beat by D
Brown and Shawn Kemp and Dominique
Wilkins I guess you're doing something
you got yeah there's no shame there no
shame whatsoever hey can you still shoot
it yeah still shoot it man oh yeah
yeah
no threes though you don't have the
range anymore I can't I can't do NBA
threes anymore I can't either I shot an
NBA three last week just I was happening
to be on the side of the Court three
feet short and then I started trying to
jump a little bit finally grazed the rim
and I was like no I'm too old for this
is it is it sad that you can't jump
anymore sad oh yes so sad what was your
vertical what was your vertical I think
it was 37 or 38 ish okay around in there
yeah yeah not not crazy but it was uh
yeah I mean especially when you grow up
and that's sort of part of who you are
uh when that's gone yeah you feel you
feel different you just feel different
but you can still shoot
well I can shoot from 12 feet and in
yeah yeah that's not not a lot of fun if
I had a shooting contest 15 feet away
you and Michael Jordan right now
right now
I'll meet 15 feet yeah me yeah
yeah me shooting contest with MJ I'll
take me and I'm not I wasn't the great I
was a great shooter I wasn't a great
maker
no no Rex you were a great scorer you
weren't okay you weren't a high
percentage shooter like you'd get on a
roll and and I could get hot yeah right
yeah that true story I didn't know how
to pump fake until I got into the NBA I
had always jumped up
I did and I never but the other part of
that Dell Curry showed me he said you
got to stay down just show the ball
because teams were saying they were
saying fly at Rex he'll just shoot it
he'll jump up and shoot it I didn't know
how to shot fake the other part of that
was I never had an open shot ever I it
wasn't I didn't know how to make an open
shot I still jumped using the same
elevation that I did on a contested
three-point shot so yes I was not a
great shooter but I could get hot in
time did you see Steph Curry as a kid
oh yeah Stefan is my my rookie year I
pulled up in Charlotte to the apartment
complex uh a week late I held out for a
week for 25 000 more yeah
um yeah and missed a week of training
camp but I pulled up to my apartment and
I got out and there were three people
standing there waiting for me to help me
load my stuff into my apartment
Sonia Curry Dell Curry and baby Stephen
Curry was about five months old so
Stefan was my first little buddy uh in
the NBA they used to bring him down once
a week go to a movie drop him off with
me and I would just hope he was alive by
the time time they came back I was nice
you babysat Steph Curry yeah absolutely
were you changing diapers changing
diapers all of that stuff
yeah that's my little buddy and I I
couldn't be more happy for him I think
if Dell Curry is one of the finest
people I've ever known and uh he's he's
uh produced two of the greatest Shooters
in the history of the game and Dell
wasn't bad himself yeah Dell was great
from the the side side yep he'd yeah let
him let him take that open jumper he was
making him uh Rex has a new podcast it's
called owned where can they uh wherever
you get your podcast wherever you get
your podcasts wherever you listen to
your podcast you can listen to own be
sure and check it out it'll be released
once a week we've got Russell Crowe out
now I think we've got Dr Jerry Buss with
Genie bus next week awesome we've got
Natalie Portman Marge shot Mukesh Ambani
Jerry Jones Roy wood JR we've got fans
of sports that come on Paul Shear it's a
it's a really fun deal I'm having a
blast with it great to talk to you again
Rex thanks buddy
you too bud play of the day is up next